[Music]
on this friday night ottawa calls the
shots
federal employees now required to get
vaccinated it's just going to push
people to get it done plus the need to
double dose before you travel phone
calls between general jonathan vance and
a woman who accused him of sexual
misconduct i just wanted to make certain
that you're
clear on our story a global news
exclusive
afghanistan's crisis as the taliban
advances how could the whole world go to
rescue a country and now stand back and
watch it collapse canada rushes to get
its citizens out and whale sanctuary the
proposed retirement home at sea
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill good
evening and thank you for joining us big
changes are coming to canada's copic 19
vaccine strategy ottawa is making
vaccination mandatory for close to half
a million public servants and it expects
employers in federally regulated
industries including banks airlines and
railways to follow suit that will impact
nearly a million more canadians
canada's vaccination rate is among the
best in the world
but to protect ourselves and each other
from the virus and its variants we must
do better
more than 82 percent of eligible
canadians have received at least one
dose and 72 percent are now fully
vaccinated against covenant 19. those
numbers are expected to rise by the fall
when the rules kick in and as abigail
beeman explains the new requirements
will extend to air train and cruise ship
passengers
first you delay me then you bump me i
can't wait to see what happens next
trains planes and not automobiles but
cruises by the end of october a
staggering number of canadians will need
to be fully vaccinated before taking an
inter-provincial trip we think the
government of canada has to lead by
example it's the country's biggest
employer the government is mandating
vaccines for the federal public service
and requiring federally regulated
employers to mandate it too that's
hundreds of thousands more canadians
everyone from bank tellers to canada
post workers plus commercial passengers
it's just going to push people to get it
done and that's what we need especially
now
you know as delta is obviously upticking
around most parts of canada mandatory
vaccination is something that i'm very
open to the announcement came late
friday right before an expected federal
election call conservative leader aaron
o'toole is clear he wants canadians to
get vaccinated but his take on this news
is not so clear his office saying
conservatives support canadians right to
determine their own health choices we
are in a crisis and canadians expect
reasonable measures such as rapid
testing
westjet and air canada also call for
rapid testing but support the
government's plan while unions and other
industries across the country scramble
to come up with responses mostly
supportive so far though some are
raising red flags the idea of making
vaccination mandatory for air and
trained travelers in particular is very
troubling for our organization in our
view this is playing politics with our
fundamental rights there are still many
big question marks the government says
there will be accommodations for people
who can't get the shot for medical
reasons but weren't so clear about
people who may not want to get it for
other reasons ministers promising they
would take the time needed to get it
right while acting fast abigail beeman
global news ottawa
now to the allegations of inappropriate
behavior facing canada's former top
soldier global news has obtained
recordings of three phone calls between
general jonathan vance and major kelly
brennan one of the women at the heart of
the allegations against him in those
calls vance is heard stressing the need
for brennan to be clear on their story
and to stick to it last month vance was
charged with one count of obstructing
justice after a military police
investigation our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stephenson has the exclusive
story
i'm preparing for armageddon here a
different kind of strategic planning for
general jonathan vance it wasn't
the important thing oh okay
that's the thing that we cannot break
in a series of phone calls made just
hours before global news published
allegations of sexual misconduct against
vance the former defense chief says he
thinks he has a strategy
vance tells major kelly brennan the
thing to keep out of this is the sex
part and repeatedly runs through plans
to coordinate their stories i just
wanted to make certain that you're
clear on our story vance warns of a
coming storm he describes as
life-changing for both of them in a bad
way
if there is
an allegation that we engaged in sexual
relations uh while i was the cbs and you
were in the military
uh
that would be
uh that would be devastating
and so it's a good thing we did brennan
told global news that vance called her
repeatedly and told her to lie setting
barriers for what she could and could
not say what i do need to do though is
make certain that you and i
are square
and that's you know you're prepared
um
to you know be able to withstand
any scrutiny at several points in the
calls vance stresses that he is telling
the truth when he describes the
relationship as not sexual you know we
just
tell the truth which is
we had an infinite relationship in
gaystown but we remain friends that
friendship extended through toronto and
here and
no sex in other parts of the calls vance
refers to the truth as i've described it
to you and raised as concerns global
news may quote have a bunch of proof in
the form of text messages or emails that
it will base a scandal a story on and
that he can cast doubt on
in the tapes brennan did not interject
to directly contradict vance but asks if
the two of them may have been seen or
captured on video and if he wants her to
write the story down brennan told global
news she felt due to the power imbalance
and being under vance's command the
instructions were like an order she
could not refuse the really really
really important thing
here um is that um
is that we did not have sex in
um
toronto
or here in ottawa yes intimate in
gaystown um
but not in
toronto and not in
um
in ottawa cities okay so
yeah
that's a line you can't cross vance also
talks about the likelihood of a military
police investigation i doubt very much
they'd
bring charges
but i just wanted to take this before
the storm starts i just wanted to make
certain that you're
clear on our story
vance has been charged with one count of
obstruction of justice court documents
cite repeated contact by vance
attempting to persuade brennan to make
false statements about their past
relationship to the police vance
previously told global news that he did
not pressure brennan in any way
including by asking her to say anything
that wasn't true vance has also denied
the allegations of sexual misconduct
vance is set to appear in court in
ottawa on september 17th mercedes
stephenson global news ottawa
we have some breaking news on the crisis
in afghanistan global news has learned
canada is deploying special forces to
help evacuate the embassy in kabul the
federal government has also announced it
will bring 20 000 vulnerable afghan
refugees to canada including female
leaders human rights defenders
journalists and family members of
previously resettled interpreters
canada will do right by those who did
right by us in an initial effort to
alleviate the emerging humanitarian
crisis in the region
canada will build
on our earlier special immigration
program
to welcome over 20 000 vulnerable afghan
refugees in total
the taliban took more provincial
capitals today in a lightning offensive
the islamist group is now in control of
more territory than at any time since
being ousted from power in 2001. its
fighters have seized kandahar
afghanistan's second largest city and
the birthplace of the taliban it has
also captured towns and territories
within a hundred kilometers of kabul as
it advances toward the capital city
there's a heightened sense of panic
across afghanistan as thousands tried to
flee from the taliban advance many
crowded the border with pakistan hoping
to cross over at one point officials had
to use their batons and those charging
the border
some 40 000 canadian troops were
deployed in afghanistan over 13 years as
part of the nato mission before pulling
out in 2014. our mike chile was on the
ground reporting on the war he looks at
what the future holds for afghanistan
the taliban posted this video to twitter
an announcement of sorts to the world
that it had captured kandahar
afghanistan's second largest
city thousands of afghans who worked in
government or who were once connected to
american and canadian forces have either
fled for the border or the capital of
kabul which experts believe could fall
within months those who stayed in their
homes have felt the taliban's wrath it's
the fear
that
we're hearing from afghans i mean i'm
just inundated on every channel and my
phone doesn't stop ringing from people
who
know someone who's died who are living
under threat who hear gunfire outside
their doors and
want to get to safety
for now omad amidi's wife is safe in
kabul while he pleads with immigration
officials in canada to allow her to join
him in manitoba
every day they speak he tells her the
same thing
nothing
just
sorry
i'm waiting i'm waiting and she's crying
all the time her fear is justified women
under the taliban were especially
oppressed when global news was reporting
on the war in 2008 we visited a
clandestine school where women learned
to read and write away from the watchful
eye of the taliban
in the ensuing years more girls were
able to attend schools and get jobs
journalist sally armstrong who has been
reporting on the war-torn country since
1997
is devastated at what the future now
holds for them
as the taliban take over a village
they're demanding a list of all girls 15
and over and all widows 44 and under and
these are the women they will give to
their fighters because every fighter is
entitled according to them to four women
i mean this is political opportunism run
amok this is crazed religious
demands that
nothing they are doing is could be found
in the koran during the american-led
occupation afghan girls had a saying
when i grow up i want to be a somebody
if the taliban takes kabul their future
could be out of their hands
microlight global news toronto
the united nations is calling on the
taliban to immediately halt its
offensive in afghanistan warning attacks
against civilians amount to war crimes
afghanistan is spinning out of control
in the last months alone more than 1 000
people have been killed or injured from
indiscriminate attacks against civilians
the u.s is rushing thousands of troops
to afghanistan to get embassy workers
out the white house says president joe
biden will evaluate the situation from
camp david this weekend other countries
are closing their embassies or reducing
staff jennifer johnson reports on the
dire situation
u.s military helicopters spotted over
the american embassy in kabul as the
taliban continues its push to
afghanistan's capital the pentagon is
sending 3 000 temporary troops to the
kabul airport to make sure embassy staff
members get out safely what we want to
be able to do is is to
get there fast and our intention is to
be able to move thousands per day the
biden administration is facing criticism
after announcing u.s troops will pull
out of afghanistan by august 31st
putting an end to america's longest
running war the mission of the afghan
government controlling its own country
never fully succeeded
some experts say the door is now open
for terrorists to rule the taliban is
going to take over the government
probably in a matter of weeks they will
allow al-qaeda back into the country i
expect extremists from around the world
will want to go to afghanistan now
britain's prime minister boris johnson
called an emergency meeting of his
security cabinet friday pledging to work
with partners in the region to keep
terrorists out but not with british
soldiers i think we've got to be
realistic about the abilities of the
the uk or any power to impose a military
solution denmark is closing its embassy
in kabul
germany is reducing its staff to a bare
minimum the united nations is also
monitoring the turmoil we're evaluating
literally on hour by hour basis there is
no evacuation
of u.n staff
going on nato envoys met friday to
discuss the unfolding disaster they said
they'll support the afghan government as
much as possible while some afghans who
worked for the alliance beg for help we
issued them he's a talent he is a
tourist we put them in the jail because
of that
if they arrest us they will kill us
everyone they will kill us the u.s and
its allies have released a statement
calling for an immediate end to taliban
attacks against cities in afghanistan
but so far the taliban is ignoring any
international pleas to stop its takeover
jennifer johnson global news washington
[Music]
backtracking on ditching pandemic
protocols coming up why alberta has
decided to keep the measures a little
longer
saskatchewan is the latest province to
sign on to the federal government's 10 a
day child care plan deputy prime
minister christopher freeland says
ottawa is committing more than a billion
dollars to the province over the next
five years ten dollar a day child care
is expected to be implemented in
saskatchewan by 2026. the funds will be
used to create 28 000 new spaces for
children under six saskatchewan is the
eighth jurisdiction to sign a child care
deal with ottawa
the alberta government is walking back
its plan to end basic coven 19 protocols
like testing and mandatory isolation for
positive cases this comes after two
weeks of strong opposition from doctors
in the province but the chief medical
officer of health says she's simply
following the latest science tom vernon
joins us now from edmonton tom what is
the new evidence that led to this change
robin dr dina hinshaw says
hospitalizations in alberta are trending
higher than they had originally forecast
they're also keeping a close eye on
rising pediatric cases south of the
border this coming monday alberta was
due to end mandatory isolation four
positive cases of covet 19. testing at
assessment centers for symptomatic
albertans was going to be wound down
they're going to end the mass mandate
for public transit taxes and ride shares
now these measures will now remain in
place for another six weeks until
september 27th the province stopped
notifying close contacts of positive
cases two weeks ago that measure will
not return now this comes after two
weeks of intense protests against the
government and strong opposition from
doctors teachers and parents among
others premier kenny has been the main
target of that anger he was noticeably
absent from today's announcement the ndp
says premier kenny is hiding from the
issue political watchers agree this
definitely isn't a good look so if he
wants to look like he's a leader which
seems to be
his desire
then
he should be taking responsibility for
his good decisions as well as the ones
that need to be modified or changed
robin the province also announced its
back-to-school plan today there will be
no province-wide mandate on masking
social distancing or co-harding those
decisions will be left up to local
school boards positive cases inside the
classroom as well as students showing
core symptoms of covet-19 will still
need to isolate robin tom vernon in
edmonton thanks tom
still ahead the fears for thousands of
british colombians as explosive
wildfires rage during another heat wave
to the state of emergency in bc where a
third summer heat wave is adding fuel to
fierce wildfires that are exploding
this is my life's work this has been my
home for 72 years
overnight 2 000 residents in logan lake
60 kilometers from kamloops fled their
homes after the tremont creek wildfire
jumped containment lines and closed in
it's one of 268 wildfires burning across
the province 51 fires started this week
12 in the last two days
it's been such a threatening emotional
time to deal with they were trying to
back burn from the road towards the fire
so it didn't cross the road obviously uh
fire is unpredictable and it will
definitely choose its own path so we've
been proactive and i think it helps but
um
there's
a lot of anxiety around being evacuated
at least 55 evacuation orders are in
effect across bc tonight there is little
relief in sight with the extreme heat
and gusty winds that will continue until
at least sunday
the province's forestry department fears
some of the fires will burn until the
snow falls
finding a home for retired whales up
next nova scotia's plan for an ocean
sanctuary
there's an ambitious effort underway to
create north america's first retirement
home for whales from marine parks the
sanctuary will be located in nova scotia
but as ross lord explains the project
faces uncharted waters there's only two
and a half years finding a better home
for captive whales is easier said than
done but a group that's been working for
five years on a whale sanctuary says
it's achieving new milestones after
considering hundreds of locations and
selecting one near sherbrooke nova
scotia organizers have established the
boundaries for a whale retirement home
the size of 84 football fields we now
have uh delineated identified
the actual
spot where the sanctuary is going to be
the sanctuary would be the first of its
kind in north america housing about a
dozen belugas and orcas whose previous
homes were entertainment parks we've
done a tremendous amount of
homework in terms of looking at
the water there the environment
uh the the tides uh all of that
whales will still be captive but in a
much larger space it isn't going to be
anything like
what they would have had in the wild in
the arctic but it's a hell of a lot
better life than they've had swimming
around a little tank for the last few
years a better life for the animals
could also mean more tourism and better
business in the sherbrooke area i mean
there are direct jobs so
that spins money into the community and
when money spins into the community uh
you know our restaurant gets gets a
piece of that money but first there's
some heavy lifting required including up
to 15 million dollars in startup costs
and 2 million in annual operating
expenses much of that money has not yet
been raised and costs can escalate
quickly the vancouver aquarium is only
now reopening after closing for a year
due to financial challenges
this british columbia center for sea
lion research was forced to close after
running out of money we needed to have
the ability to watch the site 24 hours a
day
we had constant fouling of the pins they
had to be power washed and cleaned
and anybody who lives on salt water or
nears it knows just how corrosive it is
and it is constantly destroying things
he fears if the sanctuary starts
swimming in debt taxpayers could be
forced to bail it out something laurie
mourinho insists won't happen if this is
going to happen it's going to happen
without the risk of running out of money
she says two years from now spectators
will be able to watch the whales at a
distance for free
a great deal for both sides if it comes
together as planned
ross lord global news
and that is global national for this
friday i'm robin gill we leave you
tonight with the stanley cups return to
montreal
[Applause]
the haves didn't win the cup but alex
killorn plays for the team that did the
left winger with the tampa bay lightning
grew up in beaconsfield near montreal so
today he brought the cup home to share
the glory thank you for watching have a
great night
[Music]